[Music]
you did it I have a friend for life in
you so no matter what I love you and you
did it we did it
I really wanted to be loyal to Marissa
all the way through Marissa and I were
writer dies and we made it to the final
two and I'm thrilled for her that she
won something I was thrilled about this
season watching you you put your
investigative journalism cap on and got
stuff out of Omarosa yeah I know that
air did that air I deserve some sort of
Pulitzer Prize or something right I got
the dirt did that that aired people saw
it it was every single episode there was
a nugget from Omarosa what was your
reaction to hearing all that stuff I was
just thinking this is gonna be huge
outside the house you know what I mean I
felt like you guys sent me there to get
to get it out of her and so I was on a
mission
I'm so happy people saw that oh yeah
because I'm getting stuff in the
backyard going gold they better be
putting it on the show when she told you
that we should be worried and scared
around the world it was like oh so that
with new yeah you're welcome
congratulate
[Applause]
Marisa and the brake and I go by the
villain when Julie said I won America's
player I was just so grateful you know
America gets this game the fans of this
show get this game how you have to play
it how the rules outside the world don't
apply in the Big Brother house so I'm
glad they got it yeah Julie was
surprised that you got second she thinks
people may be voted a little too
emotionally yeah I think I think the
houseguests were kind of emotional about
it all but you know thankfully that's
how it works you go in the jury they can
vote this is the first time the jury
actually got to see the show but listen
I did some running I got second place in
America's house good so I'll take it and
unlike a lot of celebrity shows that
money is yours
what are you doing that money oh I even
thought about the money at all I'll tell
you there are charities that are really
near and dear to my heart my mother
right now is bridling breast cancer I
will be making a contribution and her
name to breast cancer research but first
I want to go to happy hour I wanted to
be my dogs I just want to curl up with
those I love you know it's funny the
first few days all you think about is
your cell phone and what's going on in
the world and then you just want to hug
who you love and who you miss that's the
truth man and you want to get a haircut
because this is not good
[Music]